PLAYING: Love Me Like You Do - Ellie Goulding
-I'll pick you at five.
-I may not be done by then.
You insist on defying me, Mrs Grey.
What should i do about that?
Learn to live with it.
Oh my god. I bought it for us.
-Christian.
-This is the architect.
-I'm gonna build you a fabulous house.
Please stop speaking at my husband  as if I weren't here.
-Anna.
-You may call me Mrs. Grey
Look out your window.
I'm taking you away for the weekend.
-You own this?
-We own this.
I just can't believe this is my life that I get to live with you.
They meant nothing to me
before you.
-How are you? Anna?
-Jack, what do you want?
We're being followed.
- Do you wanna play?
-Yes sir.
Christian!
I made a vow to love you faithfully,
for soaking all others,
to comfort you in times of need,
and to keep you safe
for as long as we both shall live.
It seems you're pregnant, Mrs Grey.